[speaking indistinctly]
[militaristic music]
♪ ♪
- Hillary.
- Mr. President.
It's always good to see you.
I pretended to like you
for seven years.
You remember my anger
translator, Luther.
Good to see you,
too, Mr. President.
My hatred for you
is a pure force of nature
that is gonna move me
onward to my destiny.
And this is my anger translator,
Savannah.
I trust you've been busy.
Bet your arms are tired
from stabbing me in the back
on the campaign trail.
Saying you don't like
my foreign policy?
What the [bleep], woman?
You wrote the damn policy!
[bleep].
Well, you know how it is
to campaign for president.
You know how
this [bleep] works.
You do whatever you got to do
to get your ass elected.
And right now, you are the dead
skunk I got to step over.
Should be smooth sailing
to the nominations.
Even you couldn't [bleep] it up
against these assholes.
Well, it's too early to say,
of course.
I got this job locked down.
Unless something terrible
happens,
like you campaigning for me.
Oh, that's b--Mm.
Oh, I got a feeling
that come 2016,
you and Bill will be back
in the White House.
Yeah, and you're gonna
be busy as [bleep]
doing all the work 'cause I know
you're gonna fire them interns.
What?
[imitates explosion]
Well, I appreciate having you
as an ally, of course.
Eight years ago
I had a lock on this job,
until you showed up
out of nowhere.
- Mm.
- And you stole it from me
when you knew damn well
it was my turn.
You think I ate all that
[bleep], standing there smiling
next to my pussy-hound husband,
so I could turn around
and become Secretary of State?
Guess again, mother[bleep].
You got my job
and I'm gonna get it back.
And it's not gonna be easy
because you screwed the pooch
six ways to Sunday.
Folks just a soon vote
for a skinned possum
as a Democrat.
But that's okay.
'Cause I'm gon' do it.
I'm gonna win
this [bleep] election.
And I am gonna bury you
and every goddamn man
who ever stood in my way.
- Savannah, take it down a bit.
- And 2016 is gonna--
What is wrong with you, girl?
You are embarrassing
the future president
of the United States of America.
Have a little class.
It's always good to speak
with you, Hillary.
You a nasty-ass bitch.
Nice to talk to you, Barack.
[bleep] you, dream-stealer.
Damn, some people's
just too angry.